I also want to mention that seven of the
ten largest fires in California history
started within the past decade
chief weather caster Lonnie Quinn of our
New York station WCBS is here so Lonnie
what do you think is causing or
contributing to some of these
devastating fires okay I don't have the
precise answer I can tell you this much
Nora researchers say that both force
management and the changing climate play
a role in all this noise for forest
management wildfires you got to remember
this you need them they're nature's way
of keeping a forest healthy by clearing
dead trees and undergrowth undergrowth
but ironically firefighting advancements
over the last century it has not always
helped because what's happening is the
more land that firefighters saved in
small fires okay
just means that there's more available
land for the next large catastrophic
fire now as for that climate it all
comes down to two things hot cold wet
dry the worst calm before fire season is
going to obviously be hot and dry now
you'd expect to get those years about
25% of the time but California's
temperatures they've increased to two
even three degrees over the last century
so basically now cool is out of the
equation it's just not there anymore so
now nearly nearly every year in
California runs either hot dry or hot
wet and that means it's now a 50/50 shot
at every year of having the worst fire
conditions making matters worse there
was a five-year drought from 2011 to
2016 that drought killed more than 129
million trees
that's just fuel for the current fires
that are out there and really you got to
remember the winds it's the one thing we
haven't touched upon yet typically the
Santa Ana winds and the rainy season run
hand in hand but currently that rainy
season has been starting later which
means you get a full full month at least
a month of the dangerous winds and dry
conditions which again just exacerbates
the whole situation John Wow
Thank You Maya the best explanations
I've heard I hope so no really is yeah
very very helpful Thank You Lonnie